hello guys and welcome back
to jaegerists in today's video we will
be going through the story of light
yagami
the god of the new world in the year
2003
light yagami discovers a mysterious
notebook on the ground
at his school written on the cover are
the words death note
the death note's instructions state the
different person doesn't smash the like
button on this video
that person shall die light is initially
skeptical of the notebook's authenticity
but after experimenting with it light
realizes that the death note is real
after putting much thought into whether
or not he should continue using the
notebook
he ascertains that no one else will be
able to bear the burden of
improving the world light then meets the
previous owner of the death note
a shinigami named ryuk he explains his
reasons for dropping the death note in
the human world
and when it's light's time to die he
will be the one to write light's name in
his notebook
light then tells him of his goal of
getting rid of all evil people in the
world
and ruling over it as god light's
killings reach a monumental scale
attracting the attention of a master
detective known as
l the first conflict between light and
l happens over the television beginning
with the broadcast of lindell taylor
l places taylor as a decoy on television
in order to trick light with the network
stating that the broadcast is worldwide
taylor provokes kira
by calling him evil and in a rage
kills taylor with a heart attack light
thinks the ordeal is over
but the broadcast of taylor is suddenly
cut and l's signature
letter l appears the real l announces
that lindell taylor was a decoy and a
criminal
on death row he explains that taylor's
information
was never made available to the public
so there was no way
kira could have killed him until now l
boldly taunts kira
asking him to try and kill him as light
stares at the tv
angrily shocked that he's been fooled
we've been tricked
we've been backstabbed after several
seconds l learns that kira needs the
person's real name and face to kill the
victim
otherwise kira would have already killed
him l announces that the video was aired
only in the kanto area of japan
as a ploy to determine the location of
kira
l says that he is now speaking directly
to kira and tells kira that he will
catch him
then the broadcast ends as light ponders
over this
he accepts l's challenge to him he also
declares that he will find
l and he will eliminate him the two
announce their intentions
and both declare that they are justice
soon after
now working with the japanese police el
begins to lead a task force
alongside light's own father soichiro in
order to expose
and capture kira light hacks into his
father's computer
without leaving the trace and discovers
that l in the task force
speculate that kira may well be a
student
light figures that considering no one
would be able to control the conditions
of death
using the death note manipulating the
time of death is possible as well
light then begins killing criminals in
one hour increments
in order to specifically contradict the
kira is a student theory
letting l know that kira has access to
police information with light's main
goal in mind
being the spawning of distrust among the
police and l
as l will be bound to investigate the
police now when walking home from school
light is informed by ryuk that someone
is tailing him
in order to prevent him from being
investigated light is determined to kill
his stalker
ryuk tells light the purpose of the
death note a shinongami gets extra life
from killing humans with a death note
which is why a shinigami can live for
many years
and cannot be killed in any other way
then
ryuk explains to light that the
shinigami have eyes that allow them to
see any human's real name
and lifespan over their head in addition
a shinigami can make a deal with the
owner of the death note
to receive the shinigami eyes in
exchange for half of the human's
remaining lifespan
with ryuk offering to make the deal
light refuses the deal
stating that he needs to live for a long
time in order to rule
over his utopian world boards a bus with
his date
yuri and light's follower takes a seat
behind the couple
prior to the date light had written the
name of kichiro osorda having him hijack
the bus
then leave the bus and die of an
accident after seeing a phantom
asorta boards the bus the man pulls out
a gun and points it to the driver
taking the bus hostage light prompts his
follower to say something
by passing yuri a note which contains
light's plans to apprehend
the bus jacker light asks rey to show
him proof that he is not the bus
jacker's accomplice
forcing him to show his proof of being
an fbi agent
along with his name ray penber light
drops a note
which prompts the bus jacker to pick it
up only for the note to have been a
snippet of the death
note meaning the bus jacker can see ryuk
in shock the bus jacker empties his gun
and exits the bus
before dying in an accident back at
light's house
ruke asks him if he's going to write
down pember's name in the death note
light tells him that it would look too
suspicious if he does so immediately
after they met
in addition he wants pember to show him
the names and faces
of every fbi agent sent to investigate
the npa
on december 27th 2003 light
goes into an underground section of the
shinjuku station
light figured out that he can write the
date and cause of death
in the death note without a name and the
death note will work
when the name is added later while
wearing a hood to obscure
his identity light appears behind pember
unaware that it is light and tells
pember that he is kira
light threatens pember by stating that
non-compliance would lead to his death
light asks pember if he's carrying a
laptop and if he has a file
containing the names of all fbi agents
in japan
benber says that he doesn't have a file
like that and light hands him an
envelope
he tells pember to hold on to the
envelope take out the transmitter and
put the headphones in
over transmitter light leads pember
through a turnstile in the western
entrance
at 3 11 pm pember enters a train on the
yamanote line at 3 13
and takes a seat light asks how many fbi
agents there are
and pedbor says that he thinks there are
four groups totaling 12 agents
light says to call an agent that is
ranked lower than him and ask for the
names and faces of all agents sent to
japan
pember receives the file at 3 21 pm
and pember is the second fbi agent that
receives it
light tells pember to take out the
contents of the folder he gave him
and pember takes out four envelopes with
10 rectangular spaces
cut out of the left side of each one
light says to write down the names of
the agents
into the blocks on the folders at 4 42
pm
when rey exits the train he dies of a
heart attack while turning around
seeing light light takes the files home
and takes the pages of the death note
out of their envelope revealing the
times and causes of death for each agent
each agent will receive the file and die
at a different time
after the sudden death of rey naomi
misora decides to take part
in the kira case herself having been
told by rey that he showed his fbi badge
to someone
during a bus jacking naomi deduces that
kira must have been on the bus
in her attempts to contact the japanese
task force she comes across
light yagami light uses his father's
status to his advantage
telling naomi that he is chief yagami's
son which allows him to slowly win her
trust
cautious at first she uses the false
name shokumaki
in order to protect herself until she
can reach l after he realizes that this
was an
alias from the way ryuk laughed light
finally gets naomi to reveal her name
by saying that he is a member of the
task force and is actually working with
elle
taking advantage of naomi's emotional
state light gives the possibility
that she could join the task force and
help catch her fiance's murderer
light says that he will need to see a
form of identification before she can
join and naomi shows him her driver's
license
using a piece of the death note light
writes down naomi's name
resulting in her death by suicide as
light arrives home
he finds the doorknob of his bedroom is
strangely at the very top
plus the pencillet placed on his door
hinge is broken
not only that but his bluff a piece of
paper
was strangely put back in his door this
has light believing that elle installed
surveillance cameras and wiretaps within
his room
light then bribes ryuk with apples
asking him where the surveillance
cameras are
light reveals he has hidden scandalous
magazines and proceeds to browse
through them in order to give off the
impression to l that he is a normal
teenager
and that the magazines were what he was
hiding all along during dinner
l has a message appear on tv stating
that the icpo
has dispatched 1500 investigators to
japan
to investigate kira but light sees
through his bluff
when light is about to study for his
upcoming entrance exams he has placed a
snippet of the notebook on a mini lcd tv
within a potato chip bag while studying
whenever light places his hand into the
potato chip
he actually checks for criminals names
using the mini tv
then writes down their names the main
idea is that l would see that criminals
have died
which light could not possibly see being
busy in his room studying
with this trick light manages to kill
two petty criminals
for the next few days light proceeds to
kill more criminals
petty or not in order to cover up the
fact that petty criminals have died
solely while he was studying
eventually the surveillance cameras get
removed and light plans on finding l
through his father
light performs his entrance exams when
he notices a student
sitting strangely on his seat he passes
the exams
scoring perfectly and is able to become
a student of touhou university
alongside another student who scored
perfectly who was the student sitting
oddly earlier
he gives a speech noticing the strange
behavior of the student
who named himself after the famous pop
idol hideki ryuga
light feels annoyed at his constant
chattering that concerns light's
character
hideki ryuga then reveals himself to
light as l
light is shocked by this and is
attempting to stay calm around the
supposed new friend he's made
when light arrives home he throws a
tantrum and explains elle's strategy
that should light write down else name
using the alias
even with the off chance that it's real
the real hideaki ryuga will die
since light will have subconsciously
pictured ryuga's face
and suspicion will be pointed towards
him not only that
but even if white finds out l's real
name this l could very well be a proxy
and suspicion from the hypothetical real
l will be pointed
towards light again light accepts this
challenge from l
getting excited over this upcoming
battle of wits
l asks light to play tennis with them
and they do so nearly evenly matched
during the tennis game both of them
ponder strategies
light comes to the conclusion that l
asked him to play tennis in order to lay
the groundwork for future meetings
which will essentially be tests light
also plans on confirming that ryuga is l
with confirmation from the task force
after light wins the intense tennis
match
l reveals that he is suspicious of light
being kira
with light still being forced to put up
the act and pretends to be shocked
light comes to the conclusion that with
his act l is attempting to prevent light
from meeting with the task force
they hang out together at a cafe
afterward at the cafe
l tests light multiple times with light
managing to evade elle's psychological
traps
l asks light to help the kira
investigation if light is kira
then l will be closer to him and there
is more room for light slipping up
and if he isn't kira then his great
intellectual ability
will be of use to the investigation
light takes advantage of this
by demanding that he meet the task force
members to confirm elle's identity
in order for him to begin helping the
investigation much to light's surprise l
accepts soy turo collapses due to stress
and both light and to l visit him at the
hospital
there through soichiro light manages to
confirm that
l who appeared before him is in fact the
real
l on april 22nd 2004
in the broadcast on sakura tv kira sends
tapes
stating that if criminal reports stop
cure will kill police officers
and reporters and then demands that the
life of someone in charge of the cure
investigation
be handed over the directors or else
kira
says to choose and reveal them in four
days and that
because kira knows the director's face
there are no special requirements
however if they should choose l he must
appear on sakura tv
and give a 10-minute speech a few days
later
l asks light to join the task force
light arrives at the hotel and appears
surprised at the small size of the task
force
and l tells light that there are a few
outsiders who know what happens within
the investigation
and only one can contact l directly
light is told to look over the papers of
the investigation
then watch the tape without taking notes
or removing anything
after watching the tapes light says that
there may be someone else with kira's
abilities
citing the difference in criminals
killed as well as the fact that some
were killed immediately after
revealing their faces light realizes
that elle would have told him his plan
regardless of what he told elle and that
he set things up
so that if light didn't say there was
another kira he would look suspicious
and if he did he would help strengthen
elle's theory to the task force
l asks light to help their case by
pretending to be kira
and tells light that only he is able to
play this role
starting with writing a draft for the
speech as kira
later the tape is created and sent to
various tv stations
the second hero responds with videos
which contain indirect
and some rather direct comments about
death notes
shinigami and how they can meet light
goes to aoyama to find the second kira
but is unable to meet this kira however
due to having shinigami eyes
the second kira is able to identify
light as kira because of her
being unable to see light's lifespan
after finding out his address
the second kira arrives at light's house
and light invites misa into his room
and asks her to explain her actions misa
says that she wanted to meet kira
because her parents were murdered in
front of her and kira killed the man who
did it
misa asks to be his girlfriend admitting
that she wouldn't even mind if he simply
uses her
light agrees intending to kill her after
she outlives her usefulness
however mises shinigami rem promises to
kill him
if he ever harms misa light finds rem to
be a massive threat
as having limited control over misa
would result in her doing something
reckless
not to mention mises capture could
result in rem killing light
light now has to keep a gaggle of
girlfriends so that his newfound
relationship with misa won't stand out
as l had already deducted that kira and
the second kira have allied
misa goes directly against light's
orders and instead of meeting two weeks
after their first meeting as light
requested
misa meets up with light only two days
following their first meeting
light uses this opportunity to convince
rem to help him kill
l promising her that it's for mises
happiness rem agrees to do so
and light said that she must follow his
command only when he tells her to
at campus light surprisingly meets up
with l again where
l steals mises phone after taking
advantage of a crowd
misa is then taken away with l revealing
that he found dna
evidence in mises room pointing toward
misa being the second kira
light now concerned by l puts his master
plan into action
rem had already relinquished ownership
of misa's notebook to light
wiping her memories and preventing her
from confessing light then swaps the
notebooks with their respective
shinigami
with ryuk being attached to the notebook
originally owned by misa
and rem attached to lights light places
two fake rules and the notebook rem is
attached to
one being that when the notebook is
destroyed anyone who has touched the
notebook will die
and most importantly whoever doesn't
write names within the notebook within
13 consecutive days
dies light instructs rem to allow
kiosuki higuchi to become the new owner
of the death note she is attached to
then asks l to detain him
during his confinement no criminals die
which strengthens the case for light
being kira within seven days of
confinement light gives up his ownership
of his notebook and consequently
has all of his memories of being kira
wiped and altered
during his 15th day of confinement
criminals begin dropping dead again
and on his 50th day the task force has
l release light and misa soichiro fakes
an execution
by shooting light and misa with a blank
gun which convinces
elle to release light in misa from their
confinement light accepts elle's offer
to join the investigation team to hunt
down higuchi
l handcuffs him and light together
displeasing misa
and light elle suggests manipulating
misa in order to get information from
her
but light refuses while misa is resting
in her hotel room
elle acts lethargic about how catching
kira will be difficult
prompting light to fight him months
later l is sulking
and not working on the case light finds
a correlation between the killings
and the growth of yatsuba having the
investigation believe
that kira is either within yatsuba or
working behind yatsuba
and also leads them to the conclusion
that kira can kill through means other
than heart attacks
keeping watch at the meetings held by
the head of the yatsuba members
light objects to l letting the killings
continue
and poses as l and decides to call rishi
namikawa who agrees to help al
and postpone the killings misa
eventually finds evidence
pointing towards kiyosuki higuchi being
kira
while l in the investigation team enacts
the plan to take down higuchi light
keeps watching the situation
and follows al eventually to the point
where he is riding on a helicopter with
l
and witnesses higuchi's arrest while the
task force discovers the death note
light touches it regaining his memories
as kira once again
in order to claim ownership of the death
note he is currently holding
light kills higuchi using a snippet of
the notebook within his watch
l in the task force then find the 13 day
rule
successfully clearing light and misa of
being suspected
while l is still skeptical light
instructs misa to find her buried death
note
which results in her regaining her
memories light instructs misa to kill
l if she remembers his real name from
when they were on campus
but misa doesn't remember and so makes
the shinigami ideal again
which is what light wanted in case misa
forgot elle's name
as taking the ideal and having her life
spin would pressure rem
light then instructs misa to begin
killing criminals so that l would
suspect misa
is behind the killings this is in order
to put rem into a situation where she'd
be forced to kill
l in order to save misa ram does indeed
kill elle
and watari which results in her death
just as light planned
after winning the battle with l and
taking his persona light gains control
of the kira investigation team
this puts him on the safest ground as
his role as a second generation l
covering his identity as kira for the
next five years
by using elle's database of criminal
records light's judgments
become more widespread than ever as a
result the world falls into a dark age
which essentially everyone now lives
under the law of kira
after five years of everything going
swimmingly taki mura the head of the npa
gets kidnapped in exchange for the death
note at the same time
an fbi agent john mcenroe confronts
soichiro
and asks for the death note this fbi
agent also seeks cooperation from the
task force
to rescue takimura from the kidnappers
light feels obligated to get rid of the
kidnappers
as well as the american organization as
soon as possible
light kills takimura so that they no
longer have a bargaining chip to trade
the death note for
and it wouldn't look suspicious as
anyone could easily assume the
kidnappers killed him
however the kidnappers then announce
that they have kidnapped seiyuu yagami
which puts light under pressure
in order to get help he contacts the
organization which john mcrowe
offered to have them talk to and light
talks to nir for the first time
who introduces himself as n and is aware
of the previous
owl's death light tells near the current
situation
and nir surveys the sight of the trade
using satellites the exchange goes
through with the kidnappers
gaining the notebook near decides that
he should chase the kidnappers on his
own only for his plan to fail as mello
uses the death note to wipe out more
than half his team
light takes advantage of this incident
to trade all he knows about the notebook
for information on the perpetrator of
the kidnappings
near tells light that someone is using
the nickname melo who's using the mafia
is behind the kidnappings light learns
the location of melo and the mafia
by taking control of the current death
note owner and having him mail him their
location
light then has misa send a message to
the task force as kira
that kira relinquished ownership of his
death note to one of the members of the
task force
in order to attack the mafia and regain
the notebook
light had expected matsuda to gain
ownership and make the shinigami ideal
but unfortunately for light soichiro
does so
instead the raid commences and they
regain the death note
and light tells them to confront mello
soichiro threatens mello
rather than killing him giving jose the
opportunity to shoot soichiro severely
mellow then blows up the base and
escapes but soichiro manages to give
mello's real name
to light soichiro then dies in the
hospital after seeing that light's
lifespan
was not absent proving to him that light
was not kira
light selects demigawa as the kira
spokesperson intending to spread kira's
word
in order to gain more power and take
down nier and mello
thanks in part to david hoop's death and
the battle with the mafia the united
states submits to kira
and dissolves the spk the organization
near is running
near deducing that the second l is kira
calls light and claims that he has
interrogated mello
and learns that there are fake rules
near disproves the 13-day rule
and gives pieces of evidence to the task
force pointing towards the second l
being kira instilling some doubt within
the task force
in an effort to turn them against the
second l mello contacts mogi and tells
him to follow mello to new york which
mogi does so
under the supervision of light and the
task force however
mello has mogi go to the spk's
headquarters which puts light under
extreme pressure as mello and nir
are constantly pressuring mogi into
spilling information
luckily for light mogi doesn't give away
any information
however as he can't guarantee that and
in order to kill off nir and moki
light sends demigawa and tons of other
kira followers to attack near
however near uses elle's inheritance to
distract the crowd and escape
near lies to the task force claiming
mogi had died of a heart attack
this stirs suspicion against light which
results in azawa giving near lots of
information which has him believing that
light yagami
is the second l and kira while mogi
returns to the task force
light now expects tighter surveillance
now that nir turned the task force
against him so he has misa relinquished
ownership of her notebook to tiromikami
who kills demigawa for running amok
testifying his worth
mikami then selects kyomi takada as the
new kira spokesperson who coincidentally
had a past relationship with light
light takes advantage of this to use
takata to talk to mikami
and does this while satisfying the task
force under the guise
that he is investigating her during
their second meeting
mikami calls them and light manages to
confirm to mikami
that light is kira and mikami confirmed
to light that mikami
is the new kira proxy via subtle
communication light then says that all
the task force's surveillance cameras
and most of the wiretaps must be removed
as per akira's request
light then privately reveals to takata
that he is kira
the task force moves to japan with the
same being done
by the spk for the rest of his meetings
with takada
light and her communicate by writing
notes as the task force placed a wire on
light
light instructs takata to tell me kami
to forge a fake notebook and use that
fake notebook to write down names in
public
while he sends takata the real names so
she does the killings
near calls light and informs him of
their ongoing investigation
of takata light also has mikami savings
in public
suggesting ryuk hasn't been following
him this way
when near touches the death note he
won't think that there is no shinigami
because the notebook is fake
light's plan goes perfectly with near
having swapped the pages of mikami's
fake notebook
nir calls the task force and informs
them of a meeting
near wants to arrange taking place at
yellow box warehouse
which is just what light had expected
however not too many days before the
planned meeting
takata suddenly gets kidnapped by mello
takata successfully manages to kill melo
while light kills takata using a fire to
remove any evidence
the meeting commences and mikami begins
writing down everyone's name within the
notebook
with the only one whose name isn't
written down is confirmed to be kira
having prepared a fake all along light
had expected to win
as he had planned things out so that
mikami would bring the real one
however it is revealed to be a fake near
reveals that mikami had actually written
down takada's name
after her kidnapping not knowing light
did the same
this allowed nir to seize the real
notebook which mikami had used to write
down her name
light being exposed as kira attempts to
deny it
but with his declaration of victory as
well as the evidence near provided
everyone is convinced light is kira
light laughs maniacally and attempts to
tell them the benefits of kira's world
however near responds by saying that
everyone has a right to choose what they
think is right or wrong
while kira is killing people to
selfishly force his own personal utopia
onto everyone
when light then tries to appeal to
everyone else in the room their cold
gaze
confirms that they too harshly reject
his vision of a utopia
light then decides to distract everyone
in the room by presenting the
possibility that the notebook brought
from the task
force could be fake while mid-speech he
swiftly tries to use the scrap of his
note in his watch
to kill nir matsuda responds by shooting
light
interrupting him then berates him for
driving his own father to his death for
his vision
light then tries to continue finished
writing down the name using blood from
the gunshot wound
matsuda enraged at light shoots at light
multiple times
leaving him severely injured the task
force then disarms matsuda before he
kills light in his fit of rage
mikami commits suicide by stabbing
himself with his pen
and losing a lot of blood creating a
diversion for both the task force
and the spk although weakened light
catches a second wind
and manages to flee the warehouse near
tells azawa
mogi id and matsuda that there is no
reason to pursue light
given that there should be no more
hidden death note pieces and light's
wounds would prevent him from getting
far
izaba refuses to hedoni's orders and has
his team follow light
meanwhile ryuk writes light's name down
when he finds another warehouse to hide
in
as light silently dies an illusion of l
appears before light
mirroring a scene following elle's
defeat at light's hands
in episode 25
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos